so
welcome everybody to uh session four
of classic metal class it's uh me and
scott scott
is uh in a is it a cafe uh
or a studio uh it's a cafe
yeah but um behind this door is a
theater so it's like
major acts like pat metheny and blue
oyster cold and stuff play at this place
but this is their
front room cafe ah there we go so
today we're going to talk about a
philosophical topic and connect it to
heavy metal and both the topic itself
and the subtopic are things that scott
and i have been talking and thinking
about for a long time so we've both been
really looking forward to this show the
topic is mimesis or imitation
and how it connects with art and we're
thinking specifically about
something that that we've got mixed
feelings about
all over the map and we've we've hashed
this out in a number of different ways
and i i don't i think there's some
things we agree about and some things we
disagree about
and that's tribute bans something that's
really an important part
of the landscape not just for for metal
but for music in general but we're going
to focus on
metal bands in particular so this this
notion of mimesis or
imitation and how it connects with music
goes all the way back to
plato and aristotle they both
looked at different kinds of
of musical modes as being imitations of
different
passions or emotions so you play the
right kind of music and you get people
jazzed up you play the
another kind of music and in plato's
case you thought it was the wrong kind
of music
and people get kind of languid and
sleepy and and you know pleasure seeking
you play other kinds of music and
they're ready to go out and
fight and you know i don't think there's
a
quite such a one-to-one correspondence
between music and the soul is that
um but there it's clear that music is
imitative in some degree and if we think
about
classic heavy metal um there's imitation
going on
in a number of different ways every time
that a band plays
that that song they come out on stage
and they say hello
milwaukee how are you you know they're
they're saying something that they've
done before
and then they're going to launch into
their first song which is an
imitation of the thing that they're
they're they played on their their
record and and
when they when they recorded it it was
probably the you know
thousandth time they'd played that song
together
or in some cases maybe the second or
third time but in most cases
they've rehearsed it so music by its
very nature
and then expanding it to include the
spectacle
and all the other things is imitative um
you know scott can can talk about
this you know when you're when you're
learning songs so something that we've
talked about quite a bit
is you get a an artist who wants you to
play with them and they're like here's
the song list right you're not you're
not making this stuff
up and if you're going to be doing a
good job as the performer
as a gigging or studio musician they
don't want you to be too original right
for the most part that's a you know
that's a good point i just
did um a show with a synth pop artist uh
named casey desmond and it's very
specific
there's parts that were extremely
specific so there was
no room for me to go i'm gonna be
creative here or hit this note here
and that has to do with the sound too to
get the right sound
yeah so um yeah
or sometimes you'll have an experimental
artist saying we're hiring you for your
sound what do you add to this
but they still refine it to a degree
right they have to
and you know that's and that's what
makes it that song right
if you were if you think about guitar
solos where a guitar solo is a component
of a song so let's say just you know
crazy idea right uh iron maiden is
playing in boston
and uh you know adrian smith gets sick
and yannick airs gets
gets sick and they're like who do we
have that can can jump in right now
we need to play the trooper and they're
like well scott truly's in town
you know we know that he really likes it
and you get in there
you know when it comes to adrian smith's
parts leave yana gears out of the out of
the picture because i know
you're not a big fan of him
and he's really not doing anything great
guy it's not he's a third guitarist
but so so when you go to play you know
adrian smith's parts
if you just start like as you call it
noodling and doing some some jazz solo
is it still i mean you can still hear
the rest of the band doing the song
but you're not properly engaging in the
mesis
right and and people like what the hell
is this what's this guy doing
right it would throw everything out away
you know that's a great point um
the guitars that plays with roger waters
they did the wall tour
okay um he said
he does a comfortably numb solo on the
top of the wall in front of
20 000 people and he said that's the
most stressful thing because people paid
money for that ticket to hear that solo
and experience it the way it was on the
album
note for note
so you know there's some like you said
there's some solos that are
absolutely part of the song people want
to play air guitar to it they don't want
to hear
albeit a good guitar player a noodle
they want to hear the comfortably known
soul or
the trooper you have to play that soul
the way it is it's part of the song
i mean if i went there um i would play
adrian's stuff
nope for no because it's part of it
people expect to hear that
would you would you only do it because
people expect to hear that
and there's a little before we jump into
our main topic but i'm really curious
about
this or would it also be because you're
like well it's adrian smith
and i've been listening to him since i
was
a kid and i really admire him so i'm not
going to mess around with
his stuff it would be kind of
presumptuous of me to like
you know change it up is that is that
part of the equation
that's a big part of the equation so
let's just say bruce dickens said scott
you're doing the i want you to do your
thing tonight i would
probably it wouldn't be bruce dickinson
if you steve harris right
because if bruce dickinson said it and
then steve harris didn't like
god right you'd be screwed
so but that's a really good point
um i would say it would be out of
complete respect
for adrian smith or any anybody it would
be
you know for me and not all people look
at it that way
this is not the time for my ego this is
not the time for me to
the world what i can do this is the time
to show to pay respect
have the opportunity to pay respect and
not all i mean you could get different
musicians that will say stuff but
you hit a good point i would absolutely
um be paying tribute and respect
to one of my influences so so this is a
good kind of segway and warm-up for our
main topic of tribute bands right
because what makes a tribute band
a tribute band they're engaging in
mimesis they're engaging in imitation
and they're doing it in a very very
specific way they're not just
saying well we you know we're influenced
by iron maiden we're influenced by
motorhead or
you know the singer is influenced by do
they're actually trying
to be in some respect
a facsimile or or um
i don't want to say a knockoff i mean i
think in some cases they probably are
in bad cases but they're trying to do
something that captures
the spirit and not just the the on a
general level but down to the specifics
you know
being able to play the same notes and
take like the same stances on stage if
you're
if you're a judas priest tribute band um
you know the bassist should in some
respect resemble ian hill i think you
know
um and we could we could uh
oh i gotta let somebody in um
you know we can think about all sorts of
other topics one of the things i want to
start off at the beginning was thinking
about
what's the difference between tribute
bands and other kinds of bands that do
involve
imitation like um
parody bands or um
just cut plain old cover bands so so
let's talk about
i mean you you've talked about this
quite a bit what's the difference
between
a tribute band and a cover band
well cover band is uh you go to say a
club
and you play recognizable songs to
people
not even a specific genre so let's say
you're doing
um you know some clubs they're like can
you keep it down the first set well you
play your mellow stuff you might play
some jazz standards you might play
some soft rock um but then you know
they're like can you get the people up
dancing well you might be playing
earthwind and fire uh michael jackson
you might be playing
def leppard so it's it's it's it's stuff
that people recognize but it's not
really tribute
to a specific band or a specific thing
it's just that you're not playing your
own material you're playing stuff
to entertain and sell drinks and
you know to a degree um
quality doesn't matter that much at this
point i've seen some really bad bands
play out of tune and out of time but as
long as some of the drunk people
recognize the songs it's the
best band they've ever heard playing on
stage i think that recognizability
factor is really the key
thing they're looking for certain and
that maybe certain songs lend themselves
to that wealth they've got a really
emblematic
kind of right thing like you know like
with the trooper right when you hear the
intro you know what's the truth
when you hear you know
you know you know it's ace of spades
right yeah
we could actually do a name that too for
some little stuff
and there would be other things you're
like i don't know what the hell that
song is
i don't know what that person is playing
you know
um yeah right
you know it's funny just to cut in a lot
of original artists used to have this
terrible plan that they would say we'll
play a bunch of covers but we'll sneak
some originals in
and then they thought that they would
gain a following and that doesn't work
oh god though because your demographic
is people that want to hear
want to drink the songs they hear on the
radio and so if you're
if you're up there and you play taking
care of business yeah
you know if you play sweet home alabama
if you if you play guns and roses but
then you put in this unrecognizable song
that you've written
you lose your audience because it's
interesting because the early
um like proto and then really early
metal
albums you think about um black sabbath
black sabbath you think about
ufos first two albums
deep purples early albums they all
included covers and it was kind of like
expected that you'd have one or two
as part of what you did and then as you
you know you became a bigger band you
didn't have to do covers anymore
you know although the covers you have to
realize
um that not in every case but
in a lot of cases that could be uh the
equivalent of writing a bad song for
filler or we've got four
killer tunes yeah and you know i mean
like a lot of the songs so they're not
paying tribute to their the great artist
by doing that i mean there are some
cover songs that
really transformed you think about judas
priests
better by you better than me and
compared to the spooky tooth or green
man alicia with the two-prong crown the
fleetwood
thing isn't even remotely close to that
or of course diamonds and rust right
sure or if you think about jumping
forward wasps
um cover songs which i actually like
in some cases better than the original
like i i like the real me that wasp does
a bit better
than the original um and i think in
those cases they are paying tribute to
the artists who
who influenced them right that's you
know that
that's definitely possible although you
know it's kind of like um you know van
halen started out as a cover band if you
look at the videos on in 1975 it was all
like and that became pretty much van
halen too right
okay but you know like uh but it was you
know pretty woman the same tune except
yeah david hamming it up and eddie with
his
sound um you know it could have been
just like we need three or four more
tunes and these are songs we played
back in the day in the clubs um
you know it's hard to know it's hard to
know sometimes people do
tribute albums to a specific artist
yeah i was i was thinking about
incorporating some discussion of that
into this and i was thinking well that's
kind of a difference
different thing from an actual tribute
band it is
um it's it's sort of like a set of
covers
done by those bands in their style of of
a
artist who they really respect you know
so so when you listen to motorhead doing
a dio song
it's it's it's motorhead you know
right yeah i mean doing
if if i were to do a uh sit down and pay
money and get studio time and do
arrangements
of a song let's say a deal like a
tribute to deal
that's that's actually different than a
bunch of us getting together going
you know who should we mimic
in this scene that would make a lot of
money well we like theo
so um yeah and so we get together and
we know it we get it together because
well it's it's
uh we're going to earn money doing it
and the places will be packed and
a lot of these people were in cover
bands before but cover bands aren't even
doing as well as the tribute bands
yeah so let me let me actually we'll
take some some of the questions that are
here on the side but i want to read you
something from milwaukee magazine
kevin kosterman wrote this interesting
article called the tribute to tribute
bands
and it's like it's unholy brethren the
tribute band makes its money
playing another band's music but instead
chooses to focus on
just one act to varying degrees the band
does its best to emulate the dress stage
present instrument tone
and attitude of some of the greatest
bands in music history
i think that's a really succinct way to
define
what a tribute band is and
before so before we jump into those
questions let me re-read
emulate the dress stage presence
instrument tone and attitude and of
course the music
of the bands is he leaving any
key element out you think or does that
pretty much cover the gamut
dress stage present instrument tone
attitude music
well you know a lot of the tribute bands
now don't have any of that they just
play the songs
so down the road um there was a tom
petty tribute band it was basically a
collection of weekend warriors
um that wore khakis and um
you know they were just so they showed
up and
nobody looked like the act they didn't
have the same instruments
oh but you know they don't like
competitive music
you're tom petty music but like you know
where it's clearly a telecaster through
a vox
whatever they had in their basement and
um
so this the big you know the big part of
this that i kind of have
talked to you prior to this is you know
how much is this of the musicians
getting together and playing
and how much of this is the the uh is
society or people
paying for it and what do they expect
so yeah there's a candidate called
physical graffiti on the east coast
it was one of the few ones there was the
machine that was pink floyd
and they were spot on they sounded
exactly like it they had their
they had um the exact clothes made from
song remains the same
okay they had the exact marshals they
had john bonham's see-through set
from song remains the same and um
it was surreal because we you go to it
when i was in college and people
actually thought they were watching led
zeppelin because they had the moves down
yeah the exact instruments and it really
sounded like
soccer remains the same cranked i mean
they were
um you know that to me
that was a long time ago but that to me
was like okay that's somewhat of a fun
experience
although it's not led zeppelin but we
can't go back to 1973 madison square
garden
that was something i wanted to talk
about a little bit later on so
so let's take some of these questions so
um
mark smith says this makes me think of
an interview i watched of tony
yomi says he gets confused and people
ask him to teach them black sabbath
solos because he never plays the same
solo twice
he never commits into memory goes on the
feel i don't know if it's just a fan of
teaching but what would you would you
consider that as being is that mimesis
and i would say it is it's a certain
kind of
like staying within a kind of groove so
when he plays
um you know the solo for paranoid it may
vary from
place to place but it's not going to be
something totally
out of the blue right and so it's within
a certain kind of groove
what would you say scott um
[Music]
yeah i mean there's there's some artists
like well let's take
david gilmore from pink floyd or joe
satriani
um kind of and then they will
stick to the solo um but then you take
um
well you know if if i were to
anytime you watch any guitarist for dio
for example
yeah blasted line solo is always the
same
and i wonder if you can't say that here
we're looking at
a key distinction between an actual solo
and a set of licks that are put together
in a certain way
you know yeah i mean
i mean you can't you can't solo on the
trooper in a way that doesn't fit in
with the trooper and and
with with with dio a lot of songs are
that way too
um if you're i think it makes such a
strong statement so like
for example in my life any time i've
joined a band to play and they say we're
doing crazy train
if you don't play that randy rhodes solo
yeah you didn't
even if you play that intro riff if you
don't play the solo
it's not it's not right so it was such a
statement
i don't know i mean um i guess if the
guitarist plays this
if we talk about guitar solos the solos
every night the same way
that's one thing um
but like how much of a statement did the
solo make so all the
the vivian campbell solos i thought were
perfection note for note
every note belongs there and no matter
who
followed in his tracks after that played
guitar for dio
played those solos vote for note of
course if they were on the new album
they could play
their own solos that they came up with
but last time
um i i consider that solo part of the
song
absolutely that's just my opinion i
don't know if anybody would say
yeah just doodle away and i think what
you're saying
you know if i understand you correctly a
collection of licks together is kind of
like
no i mean i was thinking it'd be
something a bit more rigid
because the licks you play you play the
same lick
you've got to lick down right so think
of a whole sequence of them
as being i guess we should instead of
calling it that let's just call it a
melody which is what what what it is
as opposed to a guitar solo where you're
kind of um
i don't know perhaps showing off more
virtuosity and
um right spontaneity to it
you know with some guitar solos they
are essentially the melody at that point
in the sign
well you don't take um like nib
yeah i mean that's you know that's a
guitar interlude break but you have to
play that
or or or the the end part of war pig i
mean not war pigs
and part of uh paranoid yeah
if you don't play that that dreary
guitar part it's not
it that's part of the song i guess right
yeah and you can say it's an integral
part it's not it's not something
optional you could say i would agree
with that i mean personally i agree with
that
there's some parts that absolutely make
the song the way it is
um so this brings up a really
interesting point let's say we're
talking about black sabbath tribute band
and if if it's really the case that tony
yomi
improvises a good bit in his solos that
means that
in certain respects whoever is playing
tony yomi in that that black sabbath
tribute band
is sticking closer to the
recorded you know catalog solos
than um than tony omi himself is
and we don't want to say well tony aomi
is somehow you know
less in touch with black salmon he's the
originator of the stuff right
so there's kind of a weird
paradoxicality to that right
imitating too too closely could actually
be
less of an uh an imitation or
reproduction
um well you know you this is a great
point
um think about it so you're tony naomi
and you sound like tony me hope right if
you don't there's a problem
so if he improvises every night the
audience still gets
or richie blackmore yeah yeah he decides
but um let's say i joined a tribute band
and i followed this this subject
to be like um all right well you know
tony omi said he improvises so i'm just
going to improvise the problem is i'm
not tony
right so i think it makes more sense
what
you say to state the the or one of the
live versions
even if you took like from live evil or
any of those and you said you played
licks from that
you know to be a tribute man the
audience needs to
uh i mean you don't want to take these
and do like you know jazz versions of it
or change the
the meter of it because that's not
really yeah
that's not serving but you know and we
got helmet for that
but you bring up a great point you know
as long as you take it from
even you know now i'm seeing people that
do cover songs
the vocal part like i saw some woman do
reason to live
um by kiss okay and she does these
these things that aren't from the record
but are from these live videos from 88
like you know every kid show is
documented
and i can hear her singing what paul
stanley sang
in budapest 1980 or philadelphia
and it's kind of it's kind of a wink to
this fan to go
you know we all know that version but
it's still
a pulse family lick right
yeah um yeah i guess you could say that
there's the catalog
um in the sense of what's recorded
on records on masters somewhere
hopefully still existing
and then there's a broader catalog of
the bootlegs
and videos and all those those sorts of
things a wider universe
of catalog let's take a couple other
questions that are here so alfonso says
maybe the cover band because of
environmental expectation are not held
to a higher standard
a song with recognizable rifts might
might up the status of a cover ban so i
think that's what you were
saying they're they're just not um you
don't expect one
out of a cover band what would you do
out of a tribute band right
right um well you know i always use this
term sensitive layman
right so you don't have to be a musician
but a sensitive layman is somebody that
may not be a musician but really is
keyed into the art well in other words
i'm not a good distinction yeah
yeah so that's not an amateur right in
the classic sense
so yeah so you i've you know i did my
time in the bars and it was just the
drunk girls coming up staggering going
can you play
blister in the sun can you play melt
with you can you
and um and you know i've seen bands
placed very poorly
and um and i don't mean that as a
judgment i just mean like they haven't
tuned up and they're not together and
they're going the wrong sections but
people are going crazy and people go
this is the best band ever
well what they're responding to is they
know the song yeah and they're
excited about the song um
but there's but there is a picture
between listeners so like you know i've
played like
this room and there's a lot of musicians
that well not this room but the
the actual theater and um
for other artists and they're
non-musicians but they
there's something that moves them even
if they can't express it
you know there's an interesting uh
distinction that this guy paul recore
makes and i forget exactly what book he
does
and he's talking about the difference
between subjectivity and objectivity and
how people are like ah subjectivity is
bad objectivity is good
and you know when you're thinking about
like the the drunks and the
going up to the band and being like hey
man can you play
this you know uh and then if you do a
few lines from it they're like yeah that
that's recognizable as that right
that's box right so that's subjectivity
right it's purely on the side of the
subject
and whether or not it's objectively good
totally up for grabs right they don't
know
but recourse says we place too much
stress on this distinction
what we really ought to be talking about
is the difference between bad
subjectivity and good subjectivity
and i think good subjectivity captures
what you're talking about
as the person who is a kind of qualified
listener they've put in the time they're
not i mean necessarily i mean they might
be a musician
but they're not like a professional
musician themselves
but they can listen to it and be like
okay that's off that's that you're not
you know you're doing bark at the moon
and you miss these things that are in it
and i can't play it myself
but i know that jakey lee doesn't play
it like that
so i think that can be a useful way of
thinking about it it's not yet
objectivity because you can't write it
all down you know
with perfect criteria with a checklist
but there is something there well you
know there's
also that whole um you know i talk to
people it's like well you grew up with
rock
and they they might not be uh able to
say well this band
swings this jazz group swings but i go
how do you know if a band's rocking well
they don't know
you just know it if you hear it i've
said that before so if you go in
it might be the base hitting you here it
might be
the tempo it might be but that's you
know that's those are people that
are making the distinction they might
not be musicians but
you can move them even if they can't put
it into words like it's because the bass
was placed here and the kick drum was
here
no it's just a general good experience
you know that's an interesting thing to
say because
i remember going to shows where
um i would be listening to it and the
guitars would sound great and the singer
was was you know the
sounding good and the drums were usually
too loud but that's that's the way to do
it
on the base the way they'd mixed it it
was just like thumping and you couldn't
tell what was actually going on
and you you actually knew it was
supposed to be there like i remember
going to an accept show
down in in new york city where they
played with raven
and uh no it was it was uh ball taste
on on bass and um uh
wolf hoffman on guitar that was the one
actually shortly before
uh herman frank uh got fired and then
the drummer quit too
okay and any like total side note but
but
um uh hoffman was treating frank like
crap on stage you could tell that that
there was a lot of tension going on
between them and and baltis actually
looked embarrassed at certain points
but you know i knew what what peter
balthas was playing
because i knew i'd been listening i've
been listening to except since i was
like
i don't know like 14 or so so i know
with each of these canonical songs
what i'm supposed to be hearing and i
wasn't hearing it and it was because it
was mixed badly
and you know it didn't make it into a
bad performance but i was like i wish
they could have done a better job
you know i don't know who was running
boards at that time
but if i was somebody coming into it
there were a few young kids in the crowd
who you know maybe don't have that kind
of
memory built up in their head already
and they i i don't think they would have
heard a good
performance in terms of the base where
whereas the guitars were fine
you know oh you know and i found that a
lot of shows the bass is just
more of a percussive hit yeah and the
note distinction
that drives me crazy um and
um yeah it's it's disappointing because
uh you don't want to describe it goes to
show you just how contingent the
performance is right
because you can be playing great and if
the mixer
isn't doing his or her job well then
what are you going to do
you know exactly if you don't mind i
want to jump to
kay has a cool question here yeah sorry
if this goes a bit off metal end of
things but i've often thought about this
with regards to russian alex life and
solos
i like this question so far uh i
understand that the solos
he did were rather etched in stone he
has played the note for note live
yeah uh there uh there's always been a
part of me that thought wouldn't people
be interested in hearing life sin could
do
if he goes off script um
well let's take limelight there
that's uh actually i heard that
yesterday
that solo is no perfect and
honestly if i paid my ticket and i've
seen rush many times
if alex didn't play that solo um
they'd be disappointed now alex is if
you played
what if you played another solo it was
just as good though
well see that's so that's what i'm
getting at he's admittedly not a good
improver
so if i if i said alex put your note on
any
thing like you know he's i i'm a huge
alex lyson fan especially the stuff he
started with the 80s when with the
copying he did
he's a brilliant brilliant he's in my
top 10.
but if i said alex put your finger on
this string
play happy birthday from there he
probably couldn't do it first try
i don't think his musicianship is geared
towards that type of thing he didn't
focus in on that
he focused in on um a unit coming up
with these perfect parts to make a
three-piece band sound like an orchestra
and he did that like amazingly now
um it's it's interesting with the alex
lifesomething because they've always
asked like do you guys even
jam and sound check and he says not
really he goes that's not what i i can't
i i'm not really about that
so the limelight so he might have sang
but
very few of us could improvise something
that good i mean that is
the sound the the the dynamics the
you know the effects of a note fading
off and another one coming in
yeah um but in all of them it's kind of
like
very haunting very it's very post uh
andy summers to me or very post
um uh the edge so it's like after those
guys came
alex lyson's contribution to this big
worldly sound
the big money solo um but if you listen
to it the whole band is playing the solo
like the big money solo if you hear us
like listen the bass goes with
it the drums and everything builds
together if you were to improvise he'd
better be able to roll with all that
stuff
and i think what he said many times is
that's just not my in my wheelhouse
that's not what i've
worked for and um you know but
i guess early on he did like with
working man he just went for it the
early rush stuff
and it was very unfocused but it was raw
and it was
it was great for what it was but you
could tell his crafted solos
are much better than him just noodling
the licks although he did have a great
attitude and energy when he played
but i like that alex lifesomething and
like do we consider them
any degree of metal i mean maybe early
rushes
yeah yeah early rush yeah i mean they're
sort of
they're sort of metal adjacent let's say
you know
yeah it's sort of veering in and veering
out depending on
what they're they're playing you know so
yeah the early stuff was definitely post
zeppelin
yeah and you know what's with the
canadian singers like triumph singing in
the stratospheres
yeah i was just thinking about triumph
actually
let's jump into some of the other uh
things that we had lined up so
one of the things i wanted to talk about
is um when we talk about a tribute band
being good
what what actually makes them good you
know you talk about tribute bands where
it's it's basically just uh
people getting together and saying let's
play some tom petty stuff
that's not a good tribute band yet
you've got to have some of that
imitation
of some of the elements i mean you don't
necessarily it'd be hard to find
perfect physical copies of the people
that you're doing that's why kiss
tribute bands are a little bit easier to
pull off you just put everybody in
makeup right
gore would be even easier because you're
going to do all the prosthetics and
stuff
but um so you know you want some
similarities
and and you do need to have not just
musical talent but i think some
showmanship
because metal bands are you know they're
doing performances they don't
i mean we've we joked me and scott quite
a bit about richie blackmore
you know not being somebody super
engaged with the audience he's not out
there like you know on his knees you
know
he's not going to like put the guitar
behind his neck or do any any fancy
tricks like that
and he scowls at people but there is a
richie blackmore kind of
presence and if you were a deep purple
band and the guy who's playing guitar is
like you know grinning
all the time maybe that's not as good of
a performance
right i suppose if you were like a
queens right tribute band and your
singer isn't kind of
you know let's say full of himself maybe
it's not the four queens rank experience
too
you know uh and i think some musicians
would be a lot harder to pull off i mean
think about trying to be blackie lawless
in a wasp tribute band you got to play
bass you got to sing
you've got to be out there in front of
everybody you know
that would be that look without presence
yeah exactly so
there's there's all of that showmanship
the spectacle part and then there's a
similar
similarity and sound presumably you got
to like the the people that you're
you're playing or else you're not going
to be it's going to be a tough gig to do
that night after night after night
and then there's a kind of when i was
thinking about this i thought
and i don't know how to how to how to
explain this that well maybe you can
help with this scott but
you want to have the experience you want
to feel
at least to some degree like you're
not you're not necessarily seeing kiss
on stage or led zeppelin
or iron maiden but you're seeing
something that is connected to them
so there's there's some sort of essence
that you're you're
engaging with rather than just a bunch
of people who got thrown together to
make some bucks
now this is hard for me because um
as a fan and as a listener i have no
interest in tribute
bands really okay now
i do want to make a distinction before
we continue on there's different levels
i have a friend named
emily that was in brit floyd if you know
what that is that was the official pink
floyd band from
i think australia okay uh believe it or
not
brit and they would sell out
20 000 seat arenas
they were playing around the world and
she's also in rumors the fleetwood mac
tribute band
which is actually endorsed by mick
fleetwood himself
so when she was in town i went and mick
fleetwood gets up and says these are my
friends he names them and this is great
now they were actually shared like the
stems of some of the records
you know like tango in the night and
stuff and she said our job is to do it
no different than the record it's
supposed to sound exactly like the
record not like they're live
that's kind of weird isn't it because um
people go to live performances of the
band itself because they don't want to
hear
just the record if you if you go and and
a band was just playing everything
exactly like the record
you'd feel kind of like well why did i
come here you know
well but the problem is the demographic
the pace for the ticket doesn't want
that they want
exactly what the record sounds like
which i know i don't i don't agree with
it either that's why
i make the distinction this is some wild
speculation
okay but do you think that the fact that
we have
music in like digital form super easy to
listen to
you don't have all you got to do is like
click a button to hear the song again
rather than actually having to go over
and like pick the
needle up and put it back in the thing
or rewind the tape
do you think that makes do you think
that i don't want to say produce that
change but do you think that that has
some
some sort of uh factor in
wanting that i want this reproduced
exactly so i mean it's different kinds
of mimesis
in a way right although there's a
there's a variable you're missing and
that is if on my laptop
i click i'm not hearing i'm hearing a
fraction of this frequencies i should be
hearing
so if i play it on my laptop for example
or even in headphones the mp3s
are lacking a lot of the frequencies so
if you go see it live you're
hearing all the frequency now you and i
uh most of us i think grew up with
vinyl and cassettes and even if we had a
cheap sear system
we heard the bass we heard everything
yeah and as you turn the final up it got
fatter yeah right you turn an mp3 up
you'll damage your ears
so i don't know because
i guess we should ask somebody that was
born in the year 2000 or 2010
that um if they hear it live that might
be the first time they're feeling
the base here they're hearing the full
spectrum of what they should be hearing
what we grew up on which was the
industry standard was
your your parents had a receiver a
turntable nice speakers
yeah and if you were really really uh
lucky or your parents were rich they
might have a dual tape deck
the dual tape deck when your friends
came over right
can i have that that was so that we
could and we should do that we should
actually do a whole thing on this about
the transmission of tapes
that was essential for um copying music
you know somebody would have a tape and
and you know
uh bands that couldn't afford to put
something on vinyl would be a demo tape
that they'd do
and then you you dub it and then
distribute it
and uh i got to hear so many bands
precisely because of that you know
it was a great way to reproduce your own
music
true you had like a before track
recorder
if anybody you know it's like uh in the
80s it was a
recording studio that had a cassette and
you could record up to four tracks so a
guitar
you put drums down bass guitar and
vocals that was your four tracks and you
would mix it
yeah um but back to your question as as
far as like you know should it be
um uh produce uh
sound like the album well i would say
the danger you run
if the band wants to take leeway with
let's say it's an iron maiden tribute
band
and they want to veer away from it well
now you're injecting something that's
not
steve harris that's not because you
can't be steve harris i can't be adrian
smith
so if i have my own ideas that might be
something that adrian smith would never
consider or play
yeah so i think um if you're going to do
a tribute band
it's not time to if you want to be
creative
there's other ways to do it if you want
to do a tribute band
well you know die hard fans know every
note and every
you know click on this note oh you know
like this before
you know his voice cracked on this one
live album like they
know every detail and um i
yeah i'm not a as i said i'm not
somebody that would pay to go see a
tribute band
so let's let's talk about some of the
aesthetic and ethical issues that are
connected with this where i know that
that we we don't see things entirely the
same way
but there's some overlap so
one of the things that i know you wanted
to talk about and i'm going to frame it
in a very provocative way
to what degree are tribute bands
basically just riding the coattails of
the bands that they're
imitating you know they're benefiting
from the fact that
dio who's not even on the scene anymore
did all this stuff and now they get to
do it they're not like
making their own music they're making
somebody else's music and they're
they're often
you've brought up examples where a band
may
actually have trouble getting gigs in
part because they're older they need
more stuff but a tribute band is cheaper
and they'll
like get you know consistent um
business doing doing their their shows
so
i know you had some things you wanted to
say about this i'm gonna
let you have the stage for that
i think i think what you're getting at
is
what we a lot of us don't think about so
when i hit the realization that
uh i was playing a side musician to a
lot of original artists and then i have
my own original product
projects so if i go out well
you know seeing 20 people come through
the door is disappointing
although 20 years ago people would line
up down the road
and um for these things but
here's the thing at first you know i
would play this theater and it's like
well we sold 60 tickets out of 2000.
that's embarrassing yeah so anyways
at first it's like you know well this is
terrible like you know i used to sell
out
places like this but then they're like
well sorry to say but
you know the next time we book you here
because we have uh eight different
tribute bands in rotation so my first
instinct was to be angry at these
tribute bands which is silly because um
a lot of them are my friends but if you
really think about it
it's it's more of a uh
it's more of a reflection on society and
what they want
so um we can go on forever about that so
why
people in our demographic are they gonna
put down the money
you know to see dirty deeds and they'll
sell
four nights straight so you're you're
thinking 8
000 tickets um for a band to cover
what's already been done um
so it's not a reflection so much on the
musicians will do what they need to do
to survive
yeah right if they can go ahead so yeah
i was gonna so
i was gonna make a distinction here i
and i think it
um it might help with with
with that there's bands where they're
still out there doing work
touring and all that and they're still
like in good shape
to do it right um without cdc right
you know brian brian johnson can't
really sing anymore it's too dangerous
for him
um he might be able to come back but
it's not gonna be for long
um malcolm young is is gone
um angus is still playing but it's it's
not really the same thing
kiss is kind of in a similar thing i
want to talk about them in a bit because
they're they're in a weird
situation with their franchising thing
and obviously you can't put led zeppelin
back together again
so i think in cases where
the band the tribute band is allowing an
experience
that otherwise couldn't be had either
because of space or time
and i'll talk about why space matters in
just a minute i think maybe there's more
there's much more legitimacy to that to
offering that to the audience there's a
positive good being offered
now if it's a if it's a queens right ban
or let's say let's say it's um
you know we'll use queens right right
let's say they all get back together
right now i think there's still two
different queens rights out there unless
i'm mistaken but
um if you have a queens rake cover band
i will call it you know um rage for mind
crime right
i'll just make some stuff up um they're
you know they're really doing what
you're talking about they're
they're filling uh seats and filling
their pockets
kind of at the expense of the actual ban
right which isn't getting booked quite
as much
i think these are two different kinds of
situations and with the the time and
space thing
so australia has a long history going
decades back and having lots and lots
and lots of tribute bands
and the reason was is because it was so
hard to get bands to actually come to
australia because of fuel costs and you
know
you can't it's tough to bring a whole
set right and so
you know it would make sense for there
to be a rainbow tribute band
if rainbow's not gonna hit australia
although rainbow actually did hit
australia now that i remember
ronnie james dio uh was in an interview
talking about how people knew him before
he actually got there because of that
um kids show that he was in that
rock opera right yeah
yeah but i think these are i think these
are different i think that
like um so let's take kiss for example
right
gene simmons paul stanley they're i
think they're in their 70s you know
even if they manage another decade
it's it's not going to go on forever so
if if the tribute ban
becomes the way in which you actually
get to see
something like what you otherwise can't
see or
motor had right let me just go on and
the band members rightfully so said
we're never going to put together
another motorhead because
it wouldn't make any sense lemmy's gone
a motorhead tribute band i think is a
different
animal than an except tribute band
or a loudness tribute band you know
yeah i mean this is this is where i'm
kind of like a sour puss about them
no tribute bands well i mean it's
that's not fair to say but i guess um
you know that's you know as miles davis
said that's what records are for so
miles davis
to use um you know he did his era in the
50s with kind of blue and then he did
my funny valentine at the time jazz
musicians played songs on the radio
because they could improvise over it so
you know everybody would recognize the
songs they were playing
then he got into more experimental
things and people would come up to and
go why don't you play my funny valentine
why aren't you
and he goes that's what records are for
isn't that what records are for by the
record
so you know this whole notion of um
oh i would do a queens right tribute
band it's not
any disrespect to the band it's a it's
it's
shocking to know that people are will be
just as satisfied
paying for the tribute that they would
you know jeff tate is quoted joking
saying if i really wanted to make money
i joined a queen's right tribute band
well you know there's funny cases of
people from
maine bands going to audition for
tribute bands and being turned down
being told they're not enough like xyz
that's like the seinfeld where kramer
auditions for his own part
right right yeah yeah i think
you know there's there's a lot of issues
to to unpack here i think we might have
to do
another thing about this down down the
line
what we should we should probably take
some of the
questions and comments let me scroll up
a little bit
okay so this is from from mark i guess
there's also the issue of whether a band
can provide their own spin to the
material or whether it needs to be
completely faithful to the original
some people want to hear covers with
some interpretation um
i think that that's probably uh
the case although in the bar crowd maybe
not so much right
you know it comes back to sensitive
layman versus drunk i want to hear
uh rock and roll all night party every
day yeah you know
as long as you play we're waiting for
that one we don't want to hear the deep
cuts of kiss
we want the tribute band to play kiss
alive too
in the battle that's kind of a problem
that even
um bands that aren't tribute bands run
into
right one of the things so this is this
is a good segue into something that we
were going to talk about
yeah bands that effectively become
tribute bands
of themselves so i wanted to talk about
kiss and i know that you have some like
ideas about uh night ranger and def
leppard
so i'm gonna let you go first with with
those two
observations on your part um
well yeah so um you know
as far as def leppard i'm a high and dry
and pyromania fan
high and dry is probably one of my
favorite records and i remember when
hysteria came out
it took a while for me to appreciate it
but then they toured it in 1988 i think
right
am i right and they did in the round
so i didn't see that tour but i saw them
in 2001
2006. i've seen them about six times
and it's the hysteria set they play the
whole album
and then they play like uh foolin and
the hits
and i'm thinking well every summer for
the last 30 years
they've put out well they put out new
albums they never play anything from the
new album
and they won't touch anything from high
and dry
yeah and my big problem with in like
night ranger
who is a great catalog of music has a
night ranger set
that uh that they call it which is the
same set from
85 the um seven wishes tour
so mike you know and they put it they
put out records
but if you go to it as a fan and you pay
the money
you're gonna hear the bar crowd set that
i call
it but as a fan of the leopard wears
five songs off the new album whereas the
big banner about like back in the day if
a band toured
the kick drum the picture of the album
on it and they opened the first two
songs
from the new album and you hear at least
five or six
and then that happened with night ranger
and
they had an album out of the time and um
i'm friends with a couple of guys in the
band and i was backstage and i
and i brought the cd and i said you know
will you guys sign it and i said you're
gonna you're gonna be playing this
tonight
no why'd you put it out
that's good and you know i'm not naming
nate but they said well it's a night
ranger set
but that brings the question well you're
just pretty much a tribute band to the
30 year old self you what about
what about night range or what about def
leppard today
what about me hearing what music you've
made the last six seven years
exclusively and then maybe you do a
three or four song on corset with the
hits
of course i'm i'm in the i'm in the
minority on that thought
but my here's my solution so def leppard
and bands like that will play
ten thousand fifteen thousand seat
places with other bands
if they were to do a house of blues
which i think the house of blues is
about five thousand seats
they could do artistically what they
want and then five thousand die hard
fans would buy the tickets
and if you didn't like that they were
playing the deep cuts in the new album
well you know stay home
and and you see bands doing that that go
to
like you know so i mentioned seeing
except and raven at the mercy uh that
seats like i think about 300 or so
in new york city and when they're there
those bands are
are playing the old standards and
they're playing stuff off their new
albums you know
um you could say the same thing about
the chants and poughkeepsie a place that
i
i know i've been to before and seen some
good shows including udo
there um same thing you know played some
some
accept standards and some older udo
stuff and then played stuff
off the the new album so i you know i
think you're right maybe venue could
could play a role in it you know when
they know that they're with a more
serious
metal crowd uh yeah they're actual real
you're connecting with your
actual fans not the ones that heard pour
some sugar on me on the radio
and they are there to get [ __ ]
nostalgic about it
yeah yeah you know i get something
really funny to tell you so you know i'm
turning 50 and
i put together like an amazon wishlist
and it includes like concert t-shirts
and like books
basically now i saw something on there
and i told andy about this but i don't
think i told
you or anybody else about this there's
actually it's
it wasn't labeled as starter pack but it
was something like that
and it was labeled as something like you
know
rock guy shirts and there was a def
leppard shirt
there was an ac dc shirt and i forget
how
this it was and it was like it was for
people who don't know anything about
basically not even metal but even rock
and
these these would be like the shirts
that you could wear where people would
be like oh yeah i i think i've heard
those bands before
and it was labeled as if it was just for
like some dude
who doesn't really listen to anything
other than pop
before we get off the subject yeah do
you remember the family dave tour
where sam uh sammy hagar and david roth
went on tour together
oh i don't oh so what they did is they
alternated
sets so okay then i saw sammy hagar went
on first and sami hey guy did some
montrose stuff
okay get some vane stuff he did stuff
off his new album
so sami hagar and he killed it the crowd
was going bananas and then david
comes out and says you didn't want to
hear that last set
you i know what you guys all want and he
played pretty much the first few van
halen records only
he played all the biggest kids and that
was an interesting thing to me it was
like okay
we had one act come out and say let's go
back to the 70s
yeah and then we had one say okay we'll
do a little of the mantras we'll do a
little
some of the van halen we'll do my solo
stuff and we'll do
four songs for my new album and i
i love them both but i actually enjoyed
the sammy hagar set because
i'm open to hear the new stuff and
actually
most of the time if anybody's with me if
anybody can comment on this if you've
been to a concert
and you didn't have the new record but
the band played six songs from it and
they were great songs
the next day not buying the record you
know it's interesting i know we've
gotten in the habit of like getting
the new record before we go to it so we
we know what's going on but
we've seen judas priest recently uh you
know on the fire power tour
um you know saxon
i forget exactly what their their new
one that came out was but they played
they played like five songs off of that
one that's amazing i love that it's 2020
well not not with coven but yeah i want
to see what's
what's going on today i want to hear you
know you're not
you your creativity did not stop 40
years ago so i like hearing oh so this
this is a good segue into carl's
question i'm thinking about legacy type
bands bands that have revolving door
memberships and continue even after the
original members are all out of it the
temptations
uh herman's hermione plastic people of
the universe
out of prague i wonder where the line is
between legacy and tribute
so yeah that is a great question i got
to wonder if there could be a legacy
band that isn't the original band but
has the imprimiter of the original
members and a business arrangement where
the original band gets a massive cut of
the band's profit
we're going out there and extending the
brand so that is what kiss
is talking about doing and when i say
kiss i only mean gene simmons
and paul stanley not eric carr and tommy
thayer
who are who are not you know they're not
getting uh a lot of the money they're
they're
they're set they've essentially been
stand-ins for
uh peter chris and and ace freely for
you know now in tommy thayer's case i
think 20 years
and gene simmons and paul stanley are
talking about
licensing kiss getting some other people
to fill in for them
and like continuing in perpetuity
well that's not they're not the first
ones to think of that because i told you
my friend
she played in brit floyd yeah she plays
rumors
but they're sponsored by the actual
dance that's right
right right um but you know
i played for the temptations for a tour
and
you know that's a good observation
because there's one original member but
he's not really original he joined
during the cloud nine era yeah leonard
the rest of them have passed um so
it was three guys that actually were
like basketball coaches
they're really good and glenn who joined
in like the mid
70s yeah um i mean it was an honor for
me
to play these this music um but you're
right you know like we talk about
when does you talk about this last one
when is the band cease being the band so
in other words foreigner um one original
member the guitarist
yeah you know a good example like this
is thin lizzy
it's been lizzy you know i i don't see
them so for a while they were touring as
thin lizzy as and and and uh scott
gorham said
we are essentially doing a tribute to
phil
by doing this we're not going to make
any new original music we'll do that as
black star riders
and i haven't seen them tour as
thin lizzy for for a number of years now
when we saw them with
judas priest and with saxon it was as
black star riders
and they played some thin lizzy songs
but they but now they're
doing their own thing and i think thin
lizzie is effectively retired
you know well i like that idea of we're
doing a tribute to because yeah i mean
really without you
you really can't yeah i don't think you
can't have thin lizzy without you can't
have iron maiden if uh
if steve harris hangs it up that's right
yeah i think that's
that's true um the fact that bruce
dickinson left and came back and adrian
smith did show that
they're not completely indispensable
no you know that's a very good point
because there's a question though
what if steve harris was replaced by his
kid
no we were talking about wolfgang
replacing
uh uh what's his name in van halen you
know
eddie van son replacing michael anthony
yeah that's not the same as michael
anthony has his own voice and his own
base style
and i i suspect that all that was pumped
in i can't confirm that i don't want to
start rumors what do you mean by pumped
in that means that he was
the wolf gang was playing to tracks oh i
don't know if that's true
but sometimes with the harmonies
sometimes it sounds a little too much
like uh
michael anthony's vocals which is very
signature of the band
oh yeah the pace the bass parts i'm not
totally sure about and i don't want to
start rumors but i've seen some of the
stuff going
okay you put your son that's great you
keep it to the family it's really van
halen now because you got three van
halen's
but well you know i think michael
anthony was such a huge part of that
band it's hard for me to
uh well you know as long as there's
eddie
but yeah anyway yeah
no i'm i'm actually with you on that i
think that that
um you take michael anthony out of the
picture and now it's sort of like a side
project
but even with uh sammy hagar with
sylvain halen
because it was it was a different video
yeah yeah
i mean i think i i we used to call it
van hagar
and i think that was kind of right but
you know at least he
at least he came in with a whole new
sound in his own new voice and
it would have been horrible if he tried
to do the david lee roth thing
yeah i mean it's sort of like when we've
been discussing rant right so
rat is still out there touring and they
still have the two vocalists
and and they have juan crocier on base
and he's in a
very important presence but it's not
enough without warren de martini
you know i agree yeah warren d martini
is such a huge part of the sound
yeah you can't you can't replace them
with some some young young guys
let's uh let's take some of these other
yeah so andy says uh
think about the shared experience of
something like war pigs or even the
vocalization on that
all right now as a major part of the
collective fan experience
every time and actually it's not just a
priest show it's like become a standard
uh well although priest certainly does
it we see it every time a pre-show is
about to start since it's the last song
before they take the stage
and if we left that little bit off it
would feel unfinished incomplete
missing even though it's sort of like a
throwaway
um it's essentially like a vocal lick
right
all right now you know
who knows what was going through ozzie's
head when he said that
but it is it is indeed you know a
central part of that song
uh oh i see the uh since as long as
before they say stage
you're talking about andy's uh that you
just read we see it every time
that a pre-show is about to start since
the last time before they take the play
oh yeah um that's become part of the
performance too is playing
you see this in between sets right
there's like a dj and they're playing
certain songs and the whole crowd kind
of sings along to them
you know crazy what's that
we call it pa music right okay you know
like you know like a pa music meeting
like
ac dc was always in the in in the
rotation all right
right yeah you know um uh yeah
the songs to get the crowd psyched up
and um and wait for the lights to go
down right
yeah so it's it's part of the experience
anyway
it's become part of it it wasn't
originally part of it but
and and the way it became part of it is
probably kind of accidental or
contingent
you know uh things just caught on and
you know people like well let's do that
next time my guess
is like they they start it low and you
notice like as the songs go on they get
a little louder every tune
so it's almost like they're warming up
the crowd's ears um oh yeah
yeah but you know it's become you know
for me it was the big thing you go in
there and they'd be cranking
you know like artists right yeah so if
you're going to see
uh you're not gonna hear hollow notes
you're not gonna
although although uh steve harris did
say they played journey a lot
because he's a big briton fan okay and
he said the crowd would boo it
really and he said i don't care i love
journey they're an amazing band they're
we play them before we go on stage like
a bunch of their tunes
and it was the crowd them um but that
i guess that's an exception because i
think the point of the crowd
every time the song ends the crowd goes
bananas are the lights going off
yeah because it shows from the car yeah
and everyone's walking back with their
beers and
they're 15 beers all right
alfonso says maybe for metal it's a bit
difficult because many metal songs
are through composed to a large degree
parts of the song maybe
may have been improvised the writing
stage but it's repeated for performance
to performance
but it sounds like much depends on the
song's actual content
and arrangement and and maybe you could
say there's a bit more malleability
uh early on you know once you've been
playing it for 20 years you know it's
kind of
it's kind of established right kiss is
always going to play deuce the same way
nowadays right
because right songs what like almost 40
years old
maybe more right 20 yeah it's more it's
like
it's like 45 years old yeah so
oh alfonso says this might offer an
interesting
uh contrast to jazz which is highly
improvisatory and pop which
can be in between depending on the
artist so you you work in all these
genres scott
uh you're a good person to comment on
that i think
um yeah i mean jazz
i'm going to get philosophical here this
is the place
jazz to me has become a process rather
than a style
so the jazz process is making one
minutes music in one minute's time
whereas serious classical composition
and say a pop production
you can make a minute music and take
three months to make it
so but the distinction here is
making music of the moment with
intention in other words
if you know a bunch of elixir you just
throw them together that's not really
intention and that's not really music of
the moment
you're it's kind of like if i know a
bunch of words in italian
and i just start saying them i'm not
really holding a meaningful conversation
or saying anything meaningful
yeah so um like uh
he's not metal but i don't know why eric
johnson comes to mind but he's always
he'll play the song as it is but then
there'll be a section at the end where
the band will go off together right and
he might be
playing some improvisation so that to me
he's not playing the style of jazz but
he's in the jazz process
where he has intention he knows before
every note and every phrase he knows
what it's going to sound like um so
so pop but yeah if you go to pop it's it
is highly
like the thing that i just did which i
really enjoyed
was note perfect note specific and
pedal specific like i need this sound
here and the sound there
um but you know you have to wear i wear
the different hats and i enjoy
all of them i don't think one's better
than the other
um as far as if you're playing for an
artist that's different from tribute
band because i don't know if i'd ever
join a tribute band
i'd have to you know um dedicate myself
to imitating someone i was saying
i was i was actually thinking about um
no it wouldn't be a tribute band
what if like uh because i know that
you're you're friends what if buck
dharma called up and he's like listen
man my arthritis is really killing me
today
uh needs you to step in you know and
uh i know you've been you know listening
to the songs for years and years
and i want you to i don't want you to
play it just
like me though i want you to i want you
to have fun with it because that would
probably be the way
he'd talk about it right he would he
wouldn't be like
yeah he wouldn't be like i need you to
do exactly what i do
i couldn't i couldn't do no that's an
interesting point you know i would
respect his wishes
um but you know that that's his nature
is
music of the moment he doesn't play it i
think like
uh burning for you he'll play the same
way all the time but
you know he'll go into just he's all
about that moment
and sometimes he says i fall on my face
and sometimes it comes out okay
um ah i thought you know you can't i
can't sound like buck
i mean he's just got his own sound but
that's what i'm getting at if i
dedicated my life to sounding like him i
probably could but i'd be a cheap
imitation of him
and it's already been done and it's he's
not me and he was
born in a different era at a different
time went through different
he has a different past than me grew up
in a different part of you know people
grew up in new york and um that's you
know that's one of the hard things
that's
hard to pull off with tribute being is
is you know that you talk about time and
space
yeah so
you know one of the topics that i i
wanted to bring up was
you look at uh tribute bands
as sort of like talent feeders um
when you know so tommy thayer we talked
about just a minute ago
when kiss needed a a new guitarist they
plucked him out of this band called cold
jet which was a kiss tribute band
and it provided a kind of apprenticeship
for him or
you know tim ripper owens he was i mean
and
and there's i forget what movie it was
that had uh marky mark in it
rockstar that's right yeah yeah and
that's sort of
loosely based on the judas priest thing
so tim tim
owens was in a band called british steel
you know
and they you know these bands when they
were needing new
new component parts let's say they knew
what what
um places to go to to find these these
people
maybe that's not the case anymore today
where these are these are examples that
are kind of old but
it seems like tribute bands in a way
they're kind of like feeder uh
leagues for the major leagues aren't
they
well it's proven that yeah i mean really
you know um
in kiss's case ace freely was too drunk
and he
would grow up late so i went through a
couple guitars before tommy thayer
though you know
but they but like you know if you think
about it if i have a band
and a band like kiss or night ranger and
you play the same set all the time
you can find a solid tribute band and
you bet they know all the parts already
because they
play them for a living yeah yeah so what
better way to say
we have a ticket for you to come out
well
marshall set up bring your gear and
here's the set
we'll run it once at soundcheck and then
you're on tour
you know um it can be a breeding ground
absolutely uh because yeah they're ready
to come and they don't have to learn the
the 35 songs they have in rotation for
the or
they're 15 songs having a rotation for
the tour yeah
yeah i guess yeah those are two good
examples of you know somebody in the
tribute and they just
found their themselves on tour you know
it's interesting when you think about
that so i was just thinking about like
i was kind of joking around i'm not
saying that i'm as good as cliff
williams
but ac dc's nobody like listens to that
for the bass lines
although they're you know they're decent
and he he even talks in interviews about
the fact that he doesn't try to do
anything flashy
doesn't do any fills he's got a role to
play and that that's it right
um and you think well okay so really
anybody with sufficient preparation
could come in and play the root notes
you know
and the few places where the the um on
the riffs were the
bass is imitating the guitar now compare
that to steve harris
right um if you can be
steve harris in a tribute band what
can't you do
you know well
sound is a big thing of it don't forget
yeah you know
um having the right sound as a bass
player that was those classic sounds the
fender
you know where you hit it and and it
sits in the mix just the right way
is is probably greater than the notes
themselves for those bands
um and a lot of them miss it like i
always say ac dc do people do skip
sorry um uh
scooped mids right they they get rid of
all the mids and too much gain but if
you listen to ac dc records there's
hardly any
gain on those it's the base with the
guitar
with a little bit of overdrive that
makes it so heavy
yeah so it's you know perceiving it the
right way to imitate it
that would be an interesting thing for
us to do is another um
topic sometimes almost sort of like the
equivalent of
optical illusions but with sound right
so when you're listening to ac dc
you think oh i want to get that sound i
better do some distortion
nope it's exactly the opposite it's a
clean sound
with the right kind of bass as you
pointed out and i remember when you when
you explained that to me for the first
time i was like
and then i went back and listened oh
yeah exactly that's that's what's going
on and and i think there's a lot of
cases where
there are sort of let's call them sound
things that people are
are classically getting wrong they do
this with particular riffs
you know um we'll smoke on the water
everybody plays that wrong
yeah all right we ought to take some
more of these questions before we we
finish up i know i want to be respectful
of
your time so so um mark smith says bands
hardly ever come to south africa
that being said i remember there being a
phase when
ccr tribute bands were quite popular in
the pub circuit killed the band for me
i suppose hearing it too much could do
that right
well if it's not done right too i will
see ccr
if you don't have the correct tunings
that john fogarty had
the guitar is not going to resonate the
same way so people might say it's a c
chord and a d chord and this but it's
not real they're not really presenting
it sonically correctly
uh the way john fogarty would not to say
everybody does it wrong but
there's probably enough of people that
say that don't know the difference that
are performing it
yeah oh here's a good one from from cara
where does the actual band end should i
mention yes and cause trouble
will that take up the rest of this
session that's a
great one right
and for a while yet uh trevor raven was
singing lead
when john uh when john wasn't in the
band
and how can you take that voice out of
the band and it'll still be yes
so trevor raven who is you know he
joined in the 80s was singing lead
um and playing lead guitar
yeah what is it we've talked about that
when when is it not the band anymore
or when is it when is it split into like
sort of like uh you know bacteria you
know
which cell is actually the the original
cell
at a certain point it is neither of them
you know if you have split offs and
things like that
different people doing their own
projects and in in a way
so this actually does it's kind of an
interesting topic let's say you have a
band right and it's got
three main people in it and then the
rest of them are you know kind of
they're not really the writers or
anything like that when those three main
people go their separate ways
and they they bring uh they're the
nucleus for a new cell
and you got three different things out
there and each of them is playing the
same
original material right um
they're they're doing to come back to
our our original topic of mimesis
they're doing mimesis but they're each
putting their own spin on it so
you wouldn't expect um let's say
let's say that uh iron maiden broke up
right and steve harris like forms a new
band and adrian smith forms a new band
and uh steve harris forms a new band
right and they're all doing
hallow be thy name and they're in their
set list
and they've got different players it's
still gonna sound very much
like iron maiden right because they're
gonna they're gonna gravitate
most likely to people who sound kind of
similar
we've got we now we've got almost like a
cacophony of different
versions out there being being played
yeah but those those are to be side
projects playing
stuff for projects previous like sammy
hagar playing montrose stuff with his
current band right
well montrose doesn't exist anymore
right so
if it's going to be played and ronnie
montrose is dead um
even when he was right he i guess you
know when gamma ray was out there
and and sammy hager were both playing
you could have two different groups that
were playing
you know a bad motor scooter or
something right
yeah and i think that's that's different
than it
being a cover or a tribute that's that's
kind of like hey
well it's like when night ranger plays
damn yankee songs
because jack blades was in damn yankees
so yeah play a couple of the damn yankee
sets which
makes sense but i wish he wouldn't
because they have a huge catalogue and
pour out they put out that they haven't
played a thing from yeah yeah
um that's really interesting is you know
what's the distinction between
a band that is just uh turned into their
own trivia band
but you know it all comes down to the
audience and what they want to hear
um sometimes they don't even realize
that the the band's not the same you
know they're hearing
the hits from the uh like you know you'd
have to really
you know siphon out who's the sensitive
layman and who's
the die-hard fan and who is there to
hear
the two radio hits that that they grew
up with and want to
you know get drunk and yell to it um
there's nothing wrong with any of it
but you know as you're going to make
distinctions that's
that's probably something you want to
consider if you're an artist
looking for an audience which which is
it
okay so here's a question from from
carl the classic music analogy is an
interesting one but
what has to be remembered is that it all
starts with the score even if there's a
recording that's considered definitive
there's an expectation a conductor an
orchestra will have its own
somewhat elastic interpretation of a
piece this gets interesting
with players like nadja salerno
sonnenberg who established her
reputation as a soloist
who while adhering to the score she
might push the limits of the tempo
given in the score not taking liberties
but just giving herself a bit more room
for interpretation
it's a bit of a different world
conversely as as
alfonzo's pointed out recorded music
creates a weird dynamic when you're
talking about music that's heavy on
improvisation
you might have a sunrise record that's
way out there or a record of an
amm performance and if you listen to it
a thousand times
you're getting to know a moment in time
that probably couldn't ever be
reproduced live but wasn't the point of
the recording in the first place or
i mean in metal terms sweet leaf right
tony
coughing after smoking a joint and then
it getting encore
i mean it's not like it gets gets up on
stage each time and you know takes a
puff and then
coughs into the the um uh
microphone before they start playing
well this is you know as far as the
classical pieces um any
any classical performer will make a
judgment on
whether it's they're playing bach the
tempo the phrasing
so the bach violence and artisan
partitas you can listen to
10 different performances and they all
sound different although the notes are
the same
the tempos might be pushed or dragged
back intentionally
um you know gaiden cremer who did the
was
most famous for the bach violent sonatas
plays everything really slow
and um his his phrasing
is different well you know we don't have
permanent recordings from this
from the 1700s of bach we only have the
written piece
and the people that argue over the you
know
the um interpretation of it but you know
as far as
you know it's interesting there's a
whole bunch of things that are similar
to that you know in in culinary terms we
have these recipes and they're not
done in the same sort of manner as we do
recipes today
that people have to play around with or
you know like in swordsmanship
there's manuals of of you know the
drills and stuff that you would go
through and you have to kind of
imagine what the hell were they actually
trying to do
with these diagrams and stuff so yeah
that's a good point yeah i mean there's
no permanizing devices
the only catching machine so improvised
bach was a huge improviser the only way
to permanize the music was somebody to
write it down
so instead of having a tape recorder
yeah yeah yeah
the piano um the inventions were
improvised
but there was no the only permanent
device was somebody transcribing it or
him writing down what he just played
because he had a photographic memory
here
um but another point um here that
i really like is catching a snapshot
and that's what recording anything is
great because
chances are it can't happen that way
again yeah
right so this is an important thing as
far as
um any kind of performance is
let's do one last question from beatrice
uh do you think there's a right time to
stop or split
or whatever to prevent a band becoming
their own tribute band
or is it sort of a natural order to fall
into that path and repeat themselves
this is a really interesting
question it's about like the banned
process now assuming a band doesn't like
screw it up because they all get strung
out on drugs or they can't get along and
they beat each other up on the tour bus
or stuff like that
a functioning band over the decades
are they inevitably going to turn into
a you know a parody of themselves
essentially a tribute to their
20 30 year old selves or
is there a path that that keeps you from
doing that i mean we've seen successful
bands
not doing that judas priest is a great
example you know they put on great shows
there's always some new stuff
off the new album and then the old
standards some of which are being done
in sort of a lock-step way some of which
are being done in interesting ways
saxon another great example um uriah
heap
um they do stuff off their new album
they they continue you know
they go way back to 1970
what do you think is there just two
tracks
you either like manage to become the
band that
stays fresh in some way or you
inevitably
become a tribute band of yourself what
do you think scott
um you know and i wish we could have
like jack blades on this so he could
explain his side
you know from night manager um
you know to me now like jeff watson's
gone fitz is gone
um but you saw brad gillis and you saw
um
what's the drummer's name why am i
blanking such a sweet guy but
you know here's the thing
the he might argue well i've you know uh
who's who's some of them that say like
one of them called the alimony tour
right so they've got to pay alimony so
they're going to go out and play kits
yeah and um or now it would be well i
didn't have a retirement account
tour well yeah right you know did you
blow all your money
so um that's an ethical thing and
i guess i can only speak as a fan not as
of course all musicians don't think
alike yeah but you know um
you know yeah in my opinion you know
stop
while you're ahead um you know it's kind
of like the last
van halen thing was pretty upsetting to
see
or you know like you know i loved what
robert plant did i saw his tour a couple
years ago with his new record and
he played the whole new record yeah and
like jews up on three things and i
thought it was fantastic
he is not the horny 25 year old he was
in the late 60s you know that was
andy and her brothers saw him a couple
years back and had a very similar
experience
they thought it was really quite quite
wonderful and they said that when he
played the old
led zeppelin things his whole affect
changed
but well you know they say why don't you
write stuff like that anymore because
i'm not 20.
right i'm not 20 i mean you know that's
what records are for back to the miles
davis thing
yeah you know if you expect an artist to
not progress well that could be
depressing for the artist but
you know that's why i don't understand i
mean i understand the people wanting to
fill big venues and make the money by
playing the the set they did
30 years ago i get that but you know i'm
kind of surprised
um some of these bands say like you know
the thing about
like night ranger they would play dirty
d's thunder chief they would play two ac
dc tunes
or heart when i saw them they played
five cover songs
including a 15-minute version of
comfortably numb
their catalog is amazing yeah yeah but
why
why are they playing for 15 15 000
people why are they playing
paul simon tunes and you know if you
enjoy that
you could play that on your own time you
know tickets are expensive now if people
paid 150 bucks to hear heart
and they're hearing bad covers of stuff
that a bar band could do like rock and
roll by led zeppelin
yeah um but like you know the admittedly
the place emptied out i mean
noddy and i left after five songs
wow we we heard one heart song in like
whatever you know i thought we we did
that my daughter and i at summerfest
with fog hat
we uh and actually we ended up going to
see slaughter who were playing at the
same time
uh we were really excited about hearing
fog hat because i had introduced
you know she knew a few of the songs and
i was like oh this is going to be really
cool
and we got there and we were like what
the hell is this stuff you know
and and then um we were like you know
i could tell she was kind of like
getting disappointed i was like well
let's go hear slaughter and i didn't
have high expectations at all
and then we you know we crossed uh
summerfest for those who don't know is
this this uh
grounds that we have here for the
world's largest music festival
in milwaukee and you can go from stage
to stage to stage
and it sounds like it wouldn't work but
it actually does all these fans playing
at the same time
because the music the music's going off
in different directions and so we went
and
heard slaughter and it was it was
actually quite good you know
oh they're great really quick before we
go on the other hand the rolling stones
is that carl
is k carl yeah okay but here's the thing
about the rolling stones
now i'm going way back to 1989 when
steel wheels came out they were
already you know past their prime of
putting out
like big albums but when they did the
steel wheels tour they played five or
six songs from that album
the voodoo lounge was what
90s early 2000s they played and then
when i saw them
probably 15 years ago they did play four
songs from the new album
but they you know they're willing to
play two and a half hours
so you'll get you know two hours of hits
but then a half hour of the new stuff
that's a lot for for guys that old
you know and it was fantastic it was you
know i saw you know there might become a
time where it's not fantastic
and that goes back to the original
question should you stop them
yeah you know you want to remember
somebody how they were
not you know at the top of the game
yeah well this is a good place to end it
once again thanks uh scott for coming on
as a
special guest co-host um thanks for
everybody for your
your questions um you know as usual
i don't know that we got to every single
philosophical topic that we wanted to
get into but this has been a lot of fun
so we'll pick up next month we haven't
already decided a topic yet
i've got a couple kicking around in my
head
and we might have to revisit some of
these as well
so this is a big topic yeah it'd be
great yeah all right everybody have a
have a great day
you